[Music]
everyone in Academy Award bought a house
here I'll just want you know ball and of
course it how old are you 30 31 hours
you were finished yeah why wouldn't
that's going crazy then I wasn't I just
for like you know the show started going
down a little bit you know cell phone
ringing this much and my brother was
asking me my brother will come out here
from miffy's he's like what y'all doing
with that what y'all doing y'all bullets
falling off me I got to get in the
studio I'm mixing my music and then I
was like man he right man so I sold my
house and just and I always had a house
and if I just went back to Memphis and
start just doing the same things I was
doing back when I also start grinding
like I can't believe you just said that
you yeah I see why you're shaking her
head Caleb I've been saying for the last
six months a lot randomly and [ __ ] like
this I don't understand how people
understand that the thing that you
[ __ ] did to get you there is the
thing that gets you to the next level
but people think once you get to a level
now you got to change it yeah I think
that's when you got to double down on it
especially in hip-hop music yeah and the
streets are the only thing that that's
the currency now we'll do the same
street corners I hung out with the same
people
a man went to the hood shot videos and
just soaked up all that energy and I was
like man this is what I mean especially
you put it through the filter of new
[ __ ] you saw in LA you mix it a little
you take I think people go a hundred on
the street then they go to LA and it's a
hundred and I think the game for me is
100 the street now you go to LA you live
it you live a different life when you go
back to the street you take eighty of
that mm-hm but you mix it with twenty of
the new [ __ ] and then that's what I did
and I came back to LA and I was like man
I've never I feel like I've lost someone
that went back to Memphis when I can ask
him I'm gonna go back to LA I feel like
I'm losing him when I touched down in
the back of the city in Los Angeles I
will never listen to the radio I feel
like the video really miss him I head up
cuz I look the music is different you
know man it's really just the big show I
just had was like eat caviar with a 40
I would probably look at your personal
PML look at the [ __ ] are you guys up to
like what kind of vacation do you want
to take like what's your like literally
and work backwards because I genuinely
believe all of it works if you just hire
more people because if you asked me what
the counterpoint of social media is it's
text message marketing what brand is
first gonna get to a million subscribers
on text you put 80% of your energy to
squeeze Instagram 150% yeah and you
spend 20% of your energy tasting YouTube
podcasts Direct Mail conferences shows
historically I'd like to run them where
one year is profitable in the next year
is not so the growth is there but the
non profitable other every other year
was predicated on me being able to
invest in people advertising or
resources you know Boehner went one
point three four point seven fourteen
twenty seven fifty four 876 a hundred
kind of in revenue but there were dip
like we made more money at fourteen than
we did at you know fifty you know but to
me basically when you're building
something in perpetuity and you mean it
then the only thing you have to do is
make your payroll
[Music]
making videos direct to Twitter Caleb's
in the building as we are traveling and
just want to say what's up been a very
exciting day and if L free-agency
Boehner sports so much fun had an
incredible empty lines meeting just took
a flight and did a ton of vaynermedia
work
[Music]
tonight we have a gallery media group
gathering with a bunch of marketers from
different companies and really tonight's
just about shooting the [ __ ] Brian
Harwood CEO of Gallery Media Group
shooting the [ __ ] talking about
marketing different things just building
relationships you know when you're for
us we're playing forever so of course we
want to do more business with the
individuals in a room but the reality is
somebody we're gonna work for us one day
we're gonna do business in 13 years from
now so these dinners are really about
information exchange a little seed from
what I used to do at South by where we
jam session as we called it about where
the world's going so we'll do a lot of
where's the world going and marketing
tonight one of the biggest things I
believe that's happening right now that
I'm excited about as a marketer who
likes to ruin every organic platform is
that text messaging is opened up for
business has anybody here started
getting marketing on text actually real
quick no no not not fans of the people
that just raised their hands how many of
you did not have that situation three
years ago I would argue this is probably
the most interesting thing brewing
because if you asked me what the
counterpoint of social media is it's
text message marketing very personal in
your own world I'm just interested like
if a brand can what brand is first gonna
get to a million subscribers on text the
numbers are staggering it's crazy to me
there's no content
there's no articles being written about
this it's not being talked about I've
been looking like it's crazy how many
people are deep into text messaging
marketing and it's not necessarily being
talked about
[Music]
what up guys Gary B I know you've got
questions fire them at me now now a lot
more of it you're like four seconds into
it hit me back when you're 26 not when
you're 20 it's like you know I took your
advice creative long term strategy of
success but I'm three weeks in and I'm
waiting for the results
20 years dick not three minutes god this
is so [ __ ] fun sometimes I think a
lot about like what would my life be if
I was only Gary because I do so little
Gary B actually it's it's I'm actually
doing what I do I probably have a
morning show on the internet right now
distribute on all the platforms like not
you know just cuz I want to be
everywhere from like 9:00 like from 7:00
to 10:00 a.m. every morning just
answering [ __ ] questions designer
writer photographer and director Bobby
hundreds channeled his love of music and
culture into an iconic streetwear brand
the hundreds
[Music]
Facebook was partially down for some
users in the US on Wednesday this is the
worst outage Facebook has had since 2008
in many cases the platform wasn't
working at all no I got a different
point of view on it you put 80% of your
energy to squeeze Instagram 150% yeah
and you spend 20% of your energy tasting
YouTube podcasts Direct Mail conferences
shows got it you won't be because the
80% of the tension has to go somewhere
else and you've been tasting it under
20% you're talking to somebody who won
on YouTube then on Twitter then on
Facebook then on podcast that on
Instagram
got it yeah I've been doing this got it
yeah when the 80% goes away on this room
where the [ __ ] do you think all this
attention goes on the [ __ ] you've been
tasting it's like when I came out said
like snapchat for ya poppin I've been
[ __ ] tasting snapchat for two years
I saw the Khaled moment and I looked the
numbers like this is the moment yeah but
I've been tasting it right I've been
tasting LinkedIn for four years now I'm
telling people it's happening I'm still
I'm still tasting snapchat right I just
had a whole thing you know what you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you would sell it snapchat I
love it now I don't give a [ __ ] yeah no
yes I'm saying that I'm saying you're
vulnerable cuz you don't have the 20%
going hard
make your 80% of the thing that's really
working the best a.k Instagram yeah go a
hundred fifty percent hard on if not 80
person everybody's doing 100% Instagram
going 70% hard got it I'm saying yeah
[ __ ] hard hard articulated there's so
many of those hey guys thank you so much
for watching my video on YouTube I
wanted to jump in here at the end
because I'm working on a ridiculously
important project for me and I have a
funny feeling you can help if you drink
wine at all or know anybody that drinks
wine at all please go to empathy wines
calm right now and sign up for a
subscription whether it's a three pack
whether it's a six pack or whether it's
a whole case of each for the year if you
drink 36 bottles of wine a year or give
away 36 bottles of wine a year please
sign up for Club empathy this project
means the world to me I could really use
your support like a flash no cash there
my job this is one give me the eggs or
cashew nuts you're in charge